des idées courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrême de la
société
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 1er octobre 2020
l'étau se resserre paris et les
départements de la petite couronne
pourrait basculer en zone d' alerte
maximale dès lundi à déclarations
d'olivier ferrand tout à l'heure lors de
son point hebdomadaire sur l'évolution
de l'épidémie
du côté de bordeaux nice ou marseille
c'est un début d'embellie sanitaire même
si les niveaux de circulation du virus
il reste trop élevé la france est le
pays qui testent le plus au monde se
félicite le ministre de la santé avec
plus d'un million de tests réalisés par
semaine
[Musique]
coup d'envoi aujourd'hui de deux jours
de sommet européen à bruxelles
au menu des discussions notamment les
tensions en méditerranée orientale entre
la grèce et la turquie est les
vingt-sept cherchent une voie commune
face à ankara autres dossiers au coeur
des échanges la situation politique en
biélorussie a mais aussi le plan de
relance post crise sanitaire
[Musique]
le bric cite également dans les
discussions de ce sommet avec la
procédure de l'union européenne lancée
contre londres bruxelles envoie une mise
en demeure au royaume uni qui répondra
je cite en temps voulu la riposte
européenne à la suite du projet de loi
controversé de boris johnson à qui
revient en partie sur l'accord du brds
excite le spectre d'une ode il plane
toujours
[Musique]
et pour commencer retour sur le point
hebdomadaire d'olivier véran sur
l'évolution du coc vide il s'est terminé
il y à peu pour en parler nous allons
retrouver tout de suite en direct
estelle farges devant l'hôpital bichat à
paris
estelle bonsoir alors que peut-on
retenir de cette prise de parole du
ministre de la santé
pas de nouveaux tours de vis un mais une
mise en garde c'est le message adressé
par olivier ferrand lors de ce point
presse hebdomadaire une mise en garde
car le pays se trouve dans une phase
d'aggravation dans la circulation à du
virus
ce sont là les mots du ministre de la
santé cinq métropoles inquiète
particulièrement lille lyon grenoble
saint-etienne et toulouse là bas le taux
de saturation des services de
réanimation avoisine les 30% ces villes
pourraient donc être placées en zones
d'alert maximale la semaine prochaine si
les mesures actuellement à mise en place
ne produisent pas les effets escomptés
et même son de cloche pour paris et sa
petite couronne qui pourrait se voir
placé en zone d'alerté maximale et ce
dès lundi je vous propose à ce propos à
d'écouté olivier ferrand la situation de
la métropole parisienne maintenant où là
aussi vous voyez qu'il ya une
dégradation qui s'est accélérée sur
paris et la petite couronne depuis hier
en effet dans les dernières 24 heures
paris a franchi les trois seuils qui
peuvent correspondre à la zone dite d'
alerte maximale
ce franchissement des seuils nous
l'observons que depuis quelques heures
nous avons besoin évidemment de le
confirmer dans les tout prochains jours
mais si ça devait se confirmer nous
n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
placer paris et la petite couronne en
zone d' alerte maximale et ce dès lundi
enfin à concernant les villes de
marseille bordeaux ou encore nice de
timides améliorations ont été observées
mais ces résultats doivent être
confirmés dans les prochains jours un
signe d'encouragement pour olivier
ferrand à poursuivre et à tenir à les
efforts sachez enfin à que le
gouvernement va examiner dans les
proches dans les prochains jours à des
propositions des représentant es des
restaurateurs à ces derniers sont
mécontents à d'avoir dû fermer à leurs
établissements notamment à marseille et
bien si ces règles sont validées par le
haut conseil scientifique
elles pourront à permettre à ces
derniers
de garder à leur établissement ouvert
même dans les zones d' alerte maximale
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions estelle farges en direct
devant l'hôpital bichat à paris et puis
à lyon
les restaurateurs on en parlait à
l'instant sont dans le flou sur ce qu'il
va se passer dans les prochaines
semaines mais ils tenteront de s'adapter
écoutez les je ne sais pas comment ça va
se passer sur les prochains prochaines
semaines prochains mois mais on va être
au lycée adapté aux nouvelles conditions
sanitaires et flic et c'était compliqué
en ce moment avec pour la gestion le
personnel même nous la clientèle même
pour les clients ne même de savoir s'ils
doivent faire pas fait revenir après 22
heures avant 22 heures
voilà c'est compliqué mais on s'adapte
nous on est on va suivre ces mesures à
la lettre essayer un nouveau protocole
d'hygiène dont le mettra à la lèvre et
on le respecte et nous le resterons a
lyon on n'est pas touché par les 22
heures où on fait des ouvertures normale
va jusqu'à 23 heures
mais on sent vraiment énormément
une baisse de fréquentation depuis
depuis dix huit semaines et du côté de
la situation sanitaire selon les
derniers chiffres de santé publique
france en dénombre près de 14000
nouvelles contaminations au coc u19 en
24 heures soixante trois personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital et 844 patients
sont actuellement en réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests se situe
lui à 7,1 6% alors que doit-on retenir
des annonces du ministre des solidarités
de la santé sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie soulève tels des
interrogations c'est notre décryptage en
compagnie de nos invités et pour en
parler nous ont rejoints frédéric
jeanjean secrétaire général de l'ump h
des bouches du rhône c'est l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie bonsoir à vous à vos côtés
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte bonsoir est avec nous
également ce soir en duplex violaine
guérin un médecin endocrinologue bonsoir
alors justement pour commencer je vais
me tourner vers vous docteur violaine
guérin olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé a parlé d'un virus qui circulent
trop vite dans les métropoles en même
temps un frémissement positif dans
d'autres métropoles
il faudra attendre lundi pour savoir où
pas si paru si paris bascule en alerte
maximale alors comment le comprendre
ça chauffe mais la situation reste sous
contrôle où finalement le pays prend du
retard et risquent une perte de contrôle
dans les semaines à venir
alors je suis un médecin en ville et je
voulais préciser que nous ne sommes pas
du tout en train d'observer cette
panique générale qui est annoncé il me
paraît extrêmement important que la
france très rapidement modifie ces
seuils d'amplification des tests pcr
comme la falaise et récemment parce que
on est dans des statistiques qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à ce que l'on
voit nous en ville alors enfin de retour
de l'hôpital
donc le misery la santé parle d'un
million de tests ils sont et il s'en est
félicité ça ne suffit pas alors je sais
beaucoup trop de tests en fait faut
faire des tests simplement chez les
personnes symptomatique donc aujourd'hui
on fait du dépistage à tout va avec des
tests qui comprennent beaucoup de tests
faux positifs et des patients
asymptomatiques etc
donc on n'est pas du tout dans une
logique médical correct aujourd'hui
d'évaluation de la situation sanitaire
nous ne les médecins de terrain nous
pouvons comparer à ce qui se passait en
février mars avril où effectivement on
voyait des patients tous les jours sous
franco vide etc
aujourd'hui ce n'est absolument pas la
réalité et on manipule beaucoup les
données il ya même des erreurs de
données puisque j'ai lu il ya quelques
heures un article montrant des erreurs
dans les saisies de santé publique
france a priori on a vu qu'à marseille
l' ars paca à donner des évaluations qui
se ne se sont pas avérées justes
donc il ya beaucoup de à la fois je
pense d'incompétence d'erreurs et puis
surtout la santé et manipulé
actuellement pour prendre des données
des mesures qui sont extrêmement
liberticide et qui ne se justifie pas
médicalement
alors qu'on a des traitements en phase
précoce qui existe
on a certes des problèmes de tension
spital hier mais qui ne correspondent
pas à la réalité de l'épidémie qui sont
des tensions qui sont liées à la
destruction de notre système de santé
depuis des années on a encore appris
qu'on avait supprimé trois mille cinq
cents lits en 2019
ça c'est quelque chose qui se poursuit
depuis des années et quelque part moi je
suis presque un petit peu en colère par
rapport à aux médecins hospitaliers qui
certes ont manifesté fait des grèves etc
mais qui a réduit carrément arrêté de
travailler depuis un certain temps pour
que l'état français sauvent le système
de santé français et arrête de détruire
donc aujourd'hui alors on manque de lit
on
oui oui le docteur on va on va on va
revenir à mais peut-être qu'on va
entendre l'élu terrain jacquillard sur
ce que vous venez d'entendre les propos
du docteur violaine guerra vous dont le
rôle est majeur
olivier ferrand l'a souligné ce soir
j'avais il est difficile pour un maire
d'évaluer correctement la pandémie ce
matin j'étais en conciliabule est en
négociation ou puis-je en pourparlers
avec un professeur de l'hôpital foch
inns attendent aujourd'hui la montée en
puissance de la pandémie alors qu'il y
ait eu des erreurs du gouvernement et de
plusieurs gouvernements dans le passé
notamment sur les crédits qui auraient
dû être
à nous et à l'hôpital et que la notion
de service public qui a été perdu de vue
c'est exact car on est absorbé la purge
budgétaire d'une vision totalement
libérale de bruxelles et on l'a payé
très cher donc il pour retrouver de ce
côté-là des priorités nationales et des
priorités d'investissement ça c'est
évident mais je pense néanmoins que
aujourd'hui on assiste à une montée en
puissance de la pandémie et il serait
vain de croire qu'on va y échapper non
madame je suis désolé vous avez un point
de vue sachez alors vous savez chez les
médecins il ya autant d'opinions que
chez les politiques on est d'accord
voilà mais il n'en demeure pas moins il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'il y à une
montée en puissance actuellement on le
voit sur les chiffres il ne faut pas
véritablement joué avec sartre et en
tant qu'élu c'est le principe de
précaution donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on assiste sur les notions de
se laver les mains sur les notions de
distance sur le port du masque et je
crois que je peux que faire cela c'est à
dire rappeler les précautions
heureusement ça a des avantages c'est
que vous constatez vous médecin qui a
moins de gastro-entérite ou des choses
comme ça parce qu'on se touche moins les
uns les autres ou il ya un changement et
ça c'est important c'est que ce
gouvernement a compris qu'il y avait des
mères et qu' il les associe alors bien
et songez pas reçu d'appel devait rang
je suis amer d'une commune de 24
habitants est en tout cas cette volonté
de s'appuyer davantage sur les élus
locaux aujourd'hui ce que reconnaît le
gouvernement
c'est une bonne méthode et visiblement
la pentecôte est descendu sur la tête
des gouvernants et ils se sont aperçus
qu'il y avait des mères équipe allait
peut-être les associés maintenant savoir
si tout ce qui est prêt et tout ce qui
est fait est la vérité
ça c'est autre chose on compare cela aux
résultats mais ce qui est certain c'est
que en tant que maire agents de l'état
il est tout à fait légitime que et il
est même urgent
que le gouvernement s'adresse à nous
parce que quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé à marseille où sa tombe est elle
une case de jupiter ça c'est pas
admissible et il est évident que nos
amis restaurateurs ils ont raison d'une
journée même si ensuite il faut planquer
melun et bien justement frédéric
jeanjean depuis marseille est également
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie
le gouvernement parle d'une embellie 1 à
marseille olivier véran va s'entretenir
demain avec les élus locaux
l'ouverture des cafés restaurants sans
doute au menu je vous propose d'écouter
au lit et veyran vous réagissez ensuite
frédéric jeanjean
le gouvernement va dans les prochains
jours examiner les propositions qui lui
sont faites c'est normal par les
représentants du secteur de la
restauration et étudier des règles
éventuels qui pourraient permettre aux
restaurants y compris en zone d' alerte
maximale de rester en tout ou partie
ouvert mais avec des règles sanitaires
renforcés pour permettre de limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination ces
nouvelles règles si elle nous semble si
elle nous semble suffisamment robustes
protectrice contrôlable seront alors
soumises au haut conseil de santé
publique
et si elle était validée elle pourrait
alors s'appliquer dans tous les
territoires en zone d' alerte maximale
alors frédéric jeanjean caisse quand
vous réagissez à ses propos d'olivier
ferrand est ce que vous espérez un
changement de traitement dès demain
d'abord gérer quel gâchis quel gâchis
comme monsieur vers ans est descendu à
marseille la semaine dernière n'a
demandé à le rencontrer
justement pour lui proposer ces mesures
il a fallu une semaine de mobilisation
il a fallu pousser toute une filière les
cafetiers les restaurateurs et les
fournisseurs à bout pour qu'enfin il se
décide à écouter ce que nous pouvons
proposer
je trouve ça assez fort de café
parce que nous arrivons nous avons des
propositions à faire
nous connaissons nos métiers et nous
savons ce que nous pouvons avancer
et là tout d'un coup effectivement
je viens parler de la pentecôte mais je
dirais mais c'est même mieux que ça
les sourds entendent et les aveugles se
met à voir alors figurez-vous que venant
à marseille fait demain à marseille
nous avons une grande manifestation eh
bien monsieur vers ans a trouvé opportun
de nous consulter de mer en fin de
matinée parce que il s'est rendu compte
que outre les statistiques
outre une situation que nous connaissons
tous
parce que les professionnels que nous
sommes nous entendons nous voyons dans
nos proches nos familles nos clients
chez nos salariés que cette maladie pose
un problème
nous ne sommes pas inconscient nous
voulons trouver des solutions parce
qu'il faut quand même que nous puissions
vivre malgré ce virus trouver des
solutions et j'irai même plus loin
comment se fait-il que alors qu'on est
confronté cette pandémie
on voit dans les transports en commun
les choses absolument effarante et qu'on
voit ça dans toutes les métropoles et
que derrière ça dans les centres
commerciaux dans les grandes surfaces
on voit des choses tout aussi aberrante
eh bien nous les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs nous le refusons et
surtout le pays maintenant à servir de
variable d'ajustement pour la
communication d'un gouvernement qui ne
sait pas où il va alors s'il veut
trouver une direction qu'il se tourne
vers les locaux qui se tournent vers les
acteurs de terrain vers les
représentants des métiers que nous que
nous sommes nous nous pouvons avancer
des propositions des solutions nous ne
sommes pas des scientifiques
c'est pas nous qui diront aussi le sont
bonnes ou mauvaises mais nous avons
l'exemple de l'italie à côté de chez
nous où se rend compte que l'épidémie
fait moins de ravages
parce qu'ils ont vidés protocole
renforcé alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
perdu tout ce temps là pourquoi est ce
que nous nous avons perdu une semaine où
ne manquent pas pu travailler ou n'ont
pas pu créer de la richesse et cette
richesse est le servent justement
abonnés sur l'ensemble du territoire
pour aider les soignants pour aider les
gens qui sont malades pour aider les
gens qui sont en difficulté c'est ce
gâchis qui nous rend
pauvres de nous violaine des violences
graves ou qui est médecin en tant que
médecin est ce que cette touffe cette
fermeture des bars et des restaurants
même dans une métropole où le virus
circule fort activement est ce qu'elle
aurait pu être évité avec davantage de
mesures selon vous et lesquels bien sûr
que ça devrait être évitée puisque c'est
totalement incohérent et comme le
monsieur le signale quand on voit ce qui
se passe dans le métro à paris par
exemple tous les matins
ces mesures sont totalement incohérente
je rappelle au maire de maisons laffitte
que l'indicateur de surveillance de
cette pandémie
ce sont les décès et aujourd'hui tout
est manipulé avec les tests avoir un
test positif ne veut pas forcément dire
que la personne est malade ne veut même
pas forcément dire que le virus est
vivant chez cette personne si on a
trouvé du matériel génétique etc
donc si vous regardez la courbe des
décès aujourd'hui on est exactement dans
une courbe annuel classique
il faut se souvenir qu'on a selon les
jours entre 1500 et 1700 décès par jour
en france et quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui le nombre de décès annoncé
par qu'ovide et qui ne sont pas tous en
plus d'aider des annonces de décès avec
des décos vite comme coach primitive
on n'est pas du tout dans une
problématique de pandémie est en ce
moment donc toutes les mesures sont
prises sont très irrationnel et là on en
redemande que les restaurateurs
bouge il faut bouger parce que ce qui se
passe est tout à fait anormal et ça va
être c'est la mort des dpm de beaucoup
de pme etc
et c'est absolument injustifié sur le
plan médical
alors jacques myard ça c'est très
important mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il ya eu un référé parce que les gens du
monde du sport ont déposé un référé à
rennes est-il rendu par la justice et il
faut absolument que les restaurateurs
fassent pareil il faut pas lâcher le
terrain ce n'est pas justifiée
médicalement aujourd'hui alors oui en
février mars avril
il fallait prendre des mesures jacques
ni à jacques bien on entend le manque de
confiance chez violette dira mais aussi
c'est frédéric jeanjean par rapport au
gouvernement ce manque de confiance
bruno retailleau sénateur de votre
famille politique ce manque de confiance
envers le gouvernement il a souligné à
ce matin dans une interview du coup est
ce que le gouvernement finalement craint
aujourd'hui que la population ne veulent
plus accepter ces mesures alors écoutez
ce qui ce qui est évident c'est qu'il y
aie confiance vis-à-vis du gouvernement
et a ajouté à d'autres crises la paire
de la justice par exemple querelle avec
les magistrats est quelque chose d'assez
grave même peut-être encore plus grave à
terme sur la stabilité du pays
ce qui est bien à jour air sur un point
précis c'est que effectivement je le
souhaite d'ailleurs les courbes des
décès n'augmente pas mais parce qu on
est plus efficace souvent dans le
traitement de la maladie antérieure on
après des progrès de ce côté là donc ce
n'est pas vraiment un indicateur nous en
tant qu'élu madame nous sommes obligés
de prendre en compte un certain nombre
de mesures mais il y à un cohérence et
là je suis tout à fait d'accord avec mes
deux interlocuteurs à savoir qu' on nous
donne notamment des protocoles dans les
écoles qui sont de plus en plus laxiste
et on voit deuxièmement j'ai pris tout à
l'heure encore le rer à paris on peut
pas dire qu' il y ait véritablement des
mesures de distanciation les uns avec
les autres
donc c'est l'âme c'est incohérent et je
suis convaincu que
appliqué au restaurant une fermeture à
1h pourquoi cette heure dès lors que nos
amis restaurateurs prennent des mesures
de 10 ans ciation ça peut fonctionner
mais ce qui s'est passé à marseille
chers amis marseillais tu sais que un
moment il ya eu véritablement au moment
d'une victoire de foot
un mélange tout azimut et vous payez un
peu au sac si ça a été vu quand même
c'était des embrassades assez singulière
bon ce qui est clair c'est qu'on est
face à une pandémie que aujourd'hui elle
s'accélère presque bien sûr on peut
critiquer le gouvernement
mon modèle non mais attendez pour être
plus sérieux que cardiff s'est combiné
que d'une grande partie une grande
partie de l'espagne s'est continuée que
les israéliens se sont continue donc je
suis un opposant au gouvernement et à
monsieur bacon depuis toujours mais je
ne vais pas accuser le gouvernement en
disant faites attention et est le
premier ministe d'ailleurs et b rend
tout à l'heure n'a rien dit de plus il a
simplement dit on se concerte avec les
maires mais on est là pour faire
attention
donc on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui
navigue alors d'accord alors je vous
propose via le chef de l'état il ya
emmanuel macron oui je vous donne la
parole tout de suite après frédéric
jeanjean mais je vous propose avant
d'écouter emmanuel macron lui aussi
s'est exprimé ce matin sur la pandémie
on écoute il faut partout où il le peut
relancer relance est relancé et dès
maintenant il faut pas attendre que tout
soit simple que tout soit clair que tout
soit sûr et transparent parce que moi je
ne sais pas vous dire la date de fin du
virus impossible et les gens qui
d'ailleurs en face peux vous dire on
aura un vaccin au mois de mars prochain
où d'avril très sincèrement vous trompe
on va sans doute durablement vivre avec
le virus et donc il faudra expliquer des
dispositifs de freinage autre met donc à
chaque fois qu'on le peut on doit foncer
avancé croire diversifié investir alors
frédéric jeanjean quelle est votre
réaction après ses propos du chef de
l'état on doit foncer on doit investir
il a même appelé les chefs d'entreprise
à ne pas douter et qu'est ce que vous
lui
répondez aujourd'hui écoutés quand
j'entends monsieur virant dire que on
pourra manger assis mais pas boire à s'y
essayer d'ouvrir un front entre les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
je trouve ça assez cocasse et si je peux
donner un conseil au chef de l'état
c'est quand il prend la parole et qu'il
est entouré qu'il met un masque et que
les gens qui sont autour de lui mettre
un masque parce que nous c'est ce que
nous faisons quotidien dans nos
établissements
alors voilà ça c'est la première chose
ne pas douter
mais attendez pour créer la confiance il
faut des conditions et quelles sont les
conditions ce moment on navigue à vue au
séparément et en plus on nous méprise
alors là à au bout d'un moment je vais
vous dire ça commence à devenir un
exercice compliqué parce que nous
demandons à rencontrer le ministre qui
ne répondent même pas notre demande on
est obligés de mobiliser tous azimuts et
derrière ça il est obligé de revenir de
faire machine arrière
vous savez où nous en sommes dans les
bouches du rhône vous avez tous eu deux
filières
vous avez les restaurateurs les
cafetiers les hôteliers les discothèques
il faut pas les oublier
ça fait sept mois qui sont fermés sept
mois
vous avez l'esprit culture qui ne nous
rejoint jaloux milliards en temps en
tant qu'élu local en tant qu'élu local
régulière vous arrivez à faire le lien
justement cette colère j'imagine que
vous l'entendez aussi chez vos
administrés vous arrivez à la faire
remonter ou pas au gouvernement comment
ça se passe dans la commune question
d'art dans les yvelines
puisque nous avons cette chance nous ne
sommes pas astreints autant de
contraintes et de couvre-feu que à
marseille à excès et voir à paris et
donc de ce côté là on a plus de latitude
mais moi je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec ce qui est bien dire par notre ami
marseillais à savoir qu'il ya une
incohérence
d'ailleurs vous avez fait passer les
propos de vers en est ensuite les propos
du chef de l'état je suis désolé il n'y
a aucune cohérence
parce que d'un côté on vous dit il faut
investir on est bien d'accord
bon j'ai toujours pensé qu'il manque d
investissement france notamment dans les
hôpitaux comme partout ailleurs
mais ce qui est clair c'est que c'est
incohérent il ya deux discours qui sont
antinomiques dont un qui vit attention
attention c'est le tocsin et l'autre
timidement lui apprend à vivre avec mais
il faut travailler et pour que tout que
l'économie tourne c'est vrai aussi parce
que la vraie catastrophe qui risque de
nous arriver avec neuf cent mille
chômeurs de plus c'est un problème
économique donc sociologique donc
sociale et avec des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans l'impasse
donc c'est là où il ya le problème mais
il faut je dirais adapter les règles
n'ont pas de confinement mais les règles
de distanciation de façon à ce que
l'économie puisse reprendre et que l'on
est qu'on puisse mais agir avec la
précaution nécessaire mais il est je
suis d'accord une fois avec le chef de
l'état
il va falloir le vivre avec pendant
encore un bout de temps alors on va
devoir clore cet échange néanmoins
violaine guérin le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin c'est des traitements
existent en phase précoce moi je
conseille aux gens d'arrêter d'aller se
faire tester s'ils n'ont aucun symptôme
parce que ils donnent ils cautionnent un
petit peu quelque part toute cette
panique que si les gens sont malades et
bien qu'ils aillent consulter leur
médecin généraliste comme on le fait
d'habitude cette pandémie et
et première épidémie est terminée
aujourd'hui il est possible qu'au mois
d'octobre novembre
enfin fin octobre début novembre
décembre on est une
deuxième phase puisque ce virus
finalement c'est ce qu'il a fait le sar
skov un qui est classé dans la même
classe que le sascoc 2 il ya eu pendant
deux ans ddd formes cliniques mais qui
peut en plus se sont estompées sont
devenus de moins en grave tout
simplement grâce aux mutations donc bien
sûr il faut rester prudent mais il ne
faut pas empêcher le pays de fonctionner
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus de deux
choses graves qui sont en train de se
passer avec nous on voit des
augmentations de de suicides tentatives
de suicides de dépressions on voit des
dépôts de bilan dans les entreprises du
chômage et il faut simplement vivre
normalement
de tout temps il ya eu des bactéries des
virus qui se sont baladés il ya eu des
grippes il ya plein de choses là on a
rappelé aux gens aussi des règles
d'hygiène fondamentale donc ça ça n'a
pas fait de mal mais reprenons un schéma
18 ont tourné en revanche qu'il faut que
les français il faut que les français se
bougent pour sauver leur système de
santé
c'est ce qui me paraît important parce
que c'est ça aussi qu'on est en train de
payer
merci beaucoup violaine guerra d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin endocrinologue merci
avoue frédéric jeanjean secrétaire
général de l'union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie dans les
bouches-du-rhône merci à vous également
jacques myard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte est resté avec nous sur
rt france dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du sommet européen dont le
coup d'envoi a été donné aujourd'hui
avec au menu notamment les tensions
militaires à des orientales entre la
grèce et la turquie puis nous parlerons
de bréxent ips à bruxelles a
officiellement lancé une procédure
contre londres
suite au projet de loi controversé de
boris johnson a tout de suite sur rt
france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bush
vous
[Musique]
nous
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire la france
c'est un cycle de polichinelle je ne
crois pas qu'il appartient à la france
dé régler des problèmes internes
le bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train de briller le peuple il faut
demander au régime ivoiris différents
sortes d n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions la tension est à toulouse ont
demandé un report des scrutins prévus le
31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un mur
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française les vingt-sept sont donc
réunis en conseil à bruxelles pour deux
jours un sommet européen pour s'accorder
notamment sur deux crises de voisinage
immédiat en biélorussie et en turquie
face au dossier turc et aux tensions
avec la grèce est liée au partage des
eaux en méditerranée orientale
le conseil européen doit contenir doit
convenir d'une ligne de conduite avec la
mise en place d'éventuelles sanctions
le point avec françois xavier lambert
c'est un dossier aux nombreuses
conséquences diplomatiques
les tensions entre la grèce chypre et la
turquie qui revendiquent des gisements
d'hydrocarbures en méditerranée
orientale
tout l'été les trois partis ont
multiplié les provocations militaires
face à cette escalade la marge de
manoeuvre des européens est étroite
ils doivent se montrer fermes face à
ankara tout en ne compromettant pas le
dialogue avec les turcs conséquences
concrètes de ces tensions chypre
s'opposent aux sanctions contre la
biélorussie tant que les 27 ne les
soutiendront pas davantage or ce blocage
empêche l'unanimité pourtant requise
pour ce genre de décision la position
chypriote est partagé par le premier
ministre grec qui a appelé les européens
à être intransigeant face à la turquie
l'heure est venue pour l'europe de
discuter avec courage et sincérité du
genre de relation qu'elle veut vraiment
à voir avec la turquie
une chose est certaine les provocations
de la turquie que ce soit par ses
actions unilatérales ou par sa
rhétorique extrêmes ne peuvent plus être
toléré
l'appel du dirigeant grec a été entendu
par le président français emmanuel
macron assure que lui sur un solidaires
avec athènes et nicosie
il nous faut un dialogue exigeant la
solidarité à l'égard de la grèce et de
chypre et je veux être ici est très
claire cette solidarité est non
négociable
quand un état membre de l'union
européenne est attaqués menacés
lorsque
c'est authoritarian ne sont pas
respectées il est du devoir des
européens de se montrer solidaire de son
côté la chancelière allemande se montre
plus nuancé angué la merkel a assuré que
l'union européenne avait intérêt à
développer une relation constructive
avec la turquie
face à ces divisions le président turc
reste lui inflexible recep tayyip
erdogan appelle au respect des droits de
son pays pour sa part la turquie ne
cherche nullement à provoquer des
conflits détention de l'injustice ou de
l'illégalité en méditerranée nous
demandons une seule chose que l'on
montre du respect pour les droits de
notre pays ses lois et ses intérêts
c'est notre option préférée afin que les
malentendus économique et politique soit
résolue sur une base juste
malgré ce contexte diplomatique tendu un
premier signe d'apaisement a été donné
dans le cadre de l'otan la grèce et la
turquie se sont ainsi entendus pour
ouvrir une ligne directe afin d'éviter
les risques de confrontations en mer et
dans les airs
et pour revenir sur les enjeux de ce
sommet européen nous sommes avec termes
annuels thomann fondateur d'euro
continent tire emmanuel thomann bonsoir
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors un sommet européen on le
disait qu'ils se concentrent sur deux
dossiers les tensions militaires année
orientale avec le conflit grèce turquie
et la biélorussie alors sur ces dossiers
l'union européenne at elle intérêt à se
montrer capable de fermeté sur la scène
internationale est-ce qu'elle en est
capable
alors l'union européenne est
effectivement encerclés par deux années
de crise l'arc de crise méditerranéen
qui inclut évidemment le la le confie la
rivalité avec la turquie et la crise à
l'est de l'europe avec la russie et tous
les pays de l'ex urss qui aussi entre
l'union européenne et la russie l'union
européenne elle même n'a pas les clés
pour réellement peser sur aucun de ces
dossiers
car les états membres sont divisés parce
qu'ils ont une perception de sécurité
dif
rent évidemment les pays à l'est se
préoccupe de la russie et les pays
méditerranéens sont plus préoccupés par
la de crise au sud
la libye est aussi la méditerranée la
crise entre la grèce et chypre et la
turquie
il a eu son boss allez-y je vous en prie
oui nous sommes dans une situation où
l'union européenne est de plus en plus
fragmenté en réalité puisque même avec
cet accord sur le plan de relance qui
faisait espérer un sursaut d'union
européenne en fait il ya des des
rivalités entre états membres entre le
nord le sud l'est et l'ouest
et évidemment les rivalités
géopolitiques en fonction des théâtres
et des perceptions de sécurité il faut
voir aussi que l'union européenne à
cause du désaccord de leur état membre
n'a pas de stratégie géopolitique c'est
à dire n'est pas capable d'établir des
nids hérarchie et donc elle elle réagir
aux crises qui ont qui se produisent sur
son pourtour géographique
alors que là une stratégie cohérente
devrait pousser l'union européenne a
notamment à faire face à un adversaire
géopolitique de plus en plus déstabilisé
déstabilisateur qu'ils à la turquie qui
devient l'élément le plus grave pour
l'union européenne la turquie non
seulement déstabilise la ligue y
assistent ci ont ciré maintenant dans la
maintenant dans le caucase et l'union
européenne perd son temps par exemple a
essayé d'appliquer des sanctions en
biélorussie où on appelle n'a pas les
clés non plus pour mes pouces et un
changement régie pierre emmanuel
ottomane sur le dossier en méditerranée
orientale justement les vingt-sept il se
dirige plus vers des sanctions comme
vous venez d'en parler ou sur la
médiation à ce qu'elle est encore
possible où ni l'un ni l'autre
je pense que les états membres
n'arriveront pas à se mettre d'accord
sur des sanctions est en tout cas s'il y
avait quelques sanctions elles seraient
tellement dilué est faible quelques de
toute façon elles n'auront pas d'impact
sur la situation ce qui est beaucoup
plus effectif
c'est sans doute des coalitions d'état
qui essayent de contrer la turquie par
exemple lorsque la france envoie des
navires pour épauler la grèce ou sheep
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus utile
pour contrebalancer la turquie mais
union européenne elle même est trop
divisée pour un impact donc ces
sanctions n'aura pas beaucoup d'effet
mais mais ça va mais par exemple comme
chypre quand chypre met son veto à toute
mesure concernant la biélorussie tant
que la turquie n'est pas sanctionné par
l'union européenne
là ça montre bien effectivement qui va
être difficile de parler d'un front
commun
bien sûr et donc là il faut voir la
situation c'est-à-dire chypre un état
membre de l'union européenne et 2 facto
occupé par une puissance tierces la
turquie et l'union européenne n'arrive
même pas à se mettre d'accord pour
contrer la turquie alors que les
discussions pour sanctionner le régime
loukachenko alors qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment d'enjeu de sécurité grave pour
l'union européenne
donc les pays comme la grèce ou chypre
est d'ailleurs soutenue par l'autriche
et puis lit de manière plus - moins
forte mais mais aussi fermée au niveau
bilatéral par la france se préoccupe
beaucoup plus de ce qui se passe en
méditerranée mais à nouveau
l'union européenne réagit aux crises
dans son pourtour
alors qu'une le le vrai acteur qui
pourraient avoir une influence décisive
sur ces dossiers et qui aura d'ailleurs
une influence décisive sur ces dossiers
tant vis-à-vis de la turquie notamment
qui élargit
et c'est d'élargir sa zone d'influencé
en envoyant des djihadistes dans le
caucase après la syrie et la libye et
aussi pour résoudre la transition ou le
la stabilisation en biélorussie c'est la
russie est donc ce qu'ils trouvent un
intérêt géopolitique pour l'union
européenne se rapprocher la russie pour
faire face aux crises au sud en
méditerranée et vis-à-vis de la turquie
mais évidemment pour l'instant les états
membres sont trop divisés et donc ce
seront des coalition de volontaires
entre états comme par exemple la france
et la russie qui essayent de modérer le
conflit dans le caucase ou d'essayer de
d'épauler la grèce et chypre pour
contrer la turquie qui seront beaucoup
plus utile en fait
merci beaucoup pierre-emmanuel thomann
pour votre analyse votre expertise et
votre éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes fondateur
d'euro continent et l'union européenne
qui attaquent londres avec une procédure
d'infraction en cause un projet de loi
britannique remettant en question
certains de ses engagements pris avec
l'union européenne dans le cadre de son
départ bruxelles avait donné jusqu'à
hier au britannique pour retirer leur
texte
nous répondrons en temps utile a
commenté un porte parole du gouvernement
elle et précision tout de suite avec
quentin mauclair la réponse était
attendue elle est arrivée ce matin à
bruxelles après la volte face des
députés britanniques sur les accords du
bric site
l'union européenne lance sa contre
offensive par conséquent ce matin la
commission a décidé d'envoyer une lettre
de mise en demeure au gouvernement
britannique
c'est la première étape d'une procédure
d'infraction la lettre invite le
gouvernement britannique a envoyé ses
observations dans un délai d'un mois et
de plus la commission continuera à
travailler dur pour une mise en oeuvre
complète et dans les délais de l'accord
de retrait nous respectons nos
engagements
we stand by our man en septembre
bruxelles avait déjà envoyé un
avertissement aux britanniques
l'union européenne avait posé un
ultimatum au royaume uni
pour être revenu sur sa parole initial
un avertissement restée lettre morte
outre manche
pire encore mercredi dernier les députés
britanniques ont validé le projet de loi
qui revient en partie sur les accords du
bric site
ce projet de loi est par sa nature même
une violation de l'obligation de bonne
foi inscrite dans l'accord de retrait de
plus s'il est adopté tel quel il sera en
totale contradiction avec le protocole
irlande irlande du nord
la date limite a été franchie hier les
dispositions problématique n'ont pas été
retirés pour la procédure d'infraction
pourrait aller jusqu'à la cour de
justice européenne
cette décision de bruxelles est dévoilée
alors que les négociateurs des deux
parties sont depuis mardi dans la
capitale belge
ce cycle de négociations est annoncé
comme décisif pour la suite des
relations commerciales entre européens
et britanniques
l'hypothèse d'un odile devient de plus
en plus probable alors que londres et
bruxelles ont jusqu'au 31 décembre
prochain pour trouver un accord
commercial et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis londres avec martin mc
cauley analyste politique
[Musique]
bonjour martin mc cauley merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
commission européenne qui lance une
procédure d'infraction contre le royaume
uni concrètement ça veut dire quoi que
risque le royaume uni en amont dès la
fin décembre lorsque le revenu espère
tomber d'accord sur un acte juridique il
permettra de quitter l'union européenne
avec une forme d'accord cela devient
plus difficile parce que londres suit
son propre intérêt et essaye de défendre
ses intérêts l'union européenne a un
avis différent
disons qu'il s'agit d'une infraction
d'une violation du droit européen et
nous devons défendre notre point de vue
continuons à discuter sur le sujet parce
que cela rend les choses plus difficiles
pour les deux parties en prévision de
fin décembre du départ du royaume-uni
aimerait avoir
ce jour-là un accord de départ mais la
situation est maintenant beaucoup plus
long et compliqué et le temps va
commencer à manquer cependant j'espère
que l'on va trouver un compromis que le
royaume uni et l'union européenne
réussirons à trouver un accord mais avec
cette procédure est ce que la discussion
commerciale entre les deux parties est
impactée certainement car les
discussions commerciales ne se passe pas
très bien
l'accord négoce
avec l'union européenne est vu par
l'industrie britannique comme un mauvais
accord car cela signifiera beaucoup de
droits de douane chose estime certaines
personnes estiment qu'il faudrait 50 me
employés des douanes supplémentaires
pour traiter la paperasse les
négociations vont continuer on l'espère
centre espère que l'union européenne
accepte que les lois et les principes
britanniques sont équivalents au
principe européen
mais cette nouvelle protestation par
l'union européenne qui dit que le
royaume lui enfreint la loi européenne
avant la situation comme cela beaucoup
plus difficile nous ne pouvons
qu'espérer que les deux parties vont se
rassembler et trouver une solution avant
le 31 décembre alors une procédure
lancée au moment même où des
négociations se tiennent on en parlait
quel message vous lancer l'union
européenne à travers cette procédure
selon vous européenne veut montrer
qu'elle a une position très solide
qu'elle est plus forte dans ce dans ces
négociations que le royaume uni et
qu'elle ne veut pas faire de concessions
l'union européenne a des lois qu'elle
souhaite défendre et le royaume uni a
une vision différente de ces lois a une
attitude différente
le système légal système juridique
britannique était un système de
recherche de solutions les lois changent
régulièrement
la loi européenne est beaucoup plus
strictes
c'est une loi écrite qui remonte au code
napoléon c'était un système juridique
différent ce n'est pas un commando comme
on peut le trouver par exemple en
angleterre
donc c'est là que repose la difficulté
parce que les avocats eux-mêmes les
juristes sont de deux cultures
différentes et il va donc falloir
beaucoup de discussions et l'union
européenne doit donner un peu de mou et
comprendre que le royaume uni
effectivement en position difficile et
le royaume uni doit accepter que l'union
européenne a ses propres lois qui
doivent être respectées il faut trouver
un compromis et de la part des deux
parties pour conclure en quelques mots
est ce qu'on peut encore croire que les
deux parties parviendront à un accord où
finalement le no deal se profile
beaucoup de britanniques
effectivement il y aura un audit le 31
décembre
les industries britanniques notamment la
ville de londres
seul un accord ils font pression auprès
du gouvernement pour un accord
m même si c'est un mauvais accord pour
le royaume uni il faut un accord car
sans accord la situation serait bien
pire il y aurait beaucoup de confusion
le 1er janvier 2021
merci beaucoup martin mc cauley pour
votre analyse rappelle que vous êtes
analyste politique
et puis cette autre dossier chaud
abordés entre emmanuel macron et
vladimir poutine le conflit armé entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan dans le
haut-karabagh à les deux hommes
appellent avec leur homologue américain
donald trump à un cessez le feu
elle déclaration commune de moscou paris
et washington qui copréside
groupe de minsk et sur la situation dans
ce territoire dont erevan et bakou
revendique le contrôle et les combats se
sont intensifiés au cinquième jour
d'affrontements
plus de détails avec notre correspondant
à moscou antoine cléroux hier soir déjà
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine
appelé ensemble à un cessez le feu
immédiat dans cette région du sud du
caucase et au cours de la journée
d'aujourd'hui c'est le groupe de minsk
au complet qui a demandé à ce que
cessent les hostilités et à ce que les
différentes parties prenantes au conflit
entame des négociations nous président
de la fédération de russie président des
états unis d'amérique et président de la
république française représentant les
pays coprésidents du groupe de minsk à
l'oas et e condamnons dans les termes
les plus forts l'escaladé de la violence
récente sur la ligne de contact dont la
zone de conflit du haut karabagh nous
appelons à la cessation immédiate des
hostilités entre les forces militaires
concernés mais tous les dirigeants
étrangers ne semble pas être sur la même
longueur d'onde le président turc qui
soutient ouvertement l'azerbaïdjan
estime qu'il ne peut y avoir un cessez
le feu durable dans les conditions
actuelles pour lui ne peut y avoir la
paix que si l'arménie se retire des
positions qu'elles occupent au cessez le
feu pérenne dans cette région est
tributaire d'un retrait arménien de tout
le territoire azerbaïdjanais
leur quête à présent dans cessez le feu
est inacceptable la situation est donc
encore très volatile sur le terrain les
appels à la retenue semble pour
l'instant ignoré par les belligérants
qui semble donc décidé à continuer en
découdre d'autant que des acteurs
externes au conflit viendrait grossir
leurs rangs le ministère russe des
affaires étrangères a fait savoir que
des combattants des mercenaires en
provenance de syrie mais aussi de libye
serait transféré vers le haut karabagh
ce qui n'incite pas franchement à
l'optimisme
et puis sachez qu'un journalistes un
photographe du monde ont été touchée par
un bombardement dans la région ce matin
à les deux reporters vont être rapatriés
en france par avion sanitaire selon
emmanuel macron de journalistes
arméniens ont également été blessés par
ces bombardements d' après erevan sur
ces images la voiture dans laquelle
les journalistes blessés ont été
transportés et dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur le point
hebdomadaire d'olivier ferrand sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie le ministre de
la santé qui indique que le virus
circule bien trop vite dans certaines
grandes métropoles paris pourrait passer
en zone d' alerte maximale dès lundi
puis nous partirons à 18 milles
kilomètres de paris en nouvelle
calédonie l'archipel votera sur son
indépendance de la france ce dimanche à
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi toute fiabilité du projet ne
serait ce qu'au business et on oscille
entre 92 et 98 5%
elle fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
d'épaisseur on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait pour
peut-être faire en sorte qu fasse appel
à savoir faire qui est un savoir-faire
médical aussi dans un domaine un peu
différente et celui de l'animal mais
après tout l'homme c'est un manuel
populo
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise zombies des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous savez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les bilans des
entreprises pour savoir lesquels
souffrait simplement du confinement ou
du ralentissement de l'activité et les
qu'elle était déjà en état de deux morts
avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production besson
les impôts sur les entreprises qui
marchent et donc qui font du résultat
celles qui sont déjà son billet
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts vous n'allez
pas leur donner de l'argent en fait
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
morales un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chouhada et tout le monde
discute est finalement que mon discuter
ils sont trouvés entre le même drapeau
libanais pour une fois vous voyez des
images assez touchants de l'armée qui
était presque impliqué avec les
manifestants aujourd'hui on sent que le
ton a changé c'est la pause des hommes
politiques et sont en train de manipuler
l'armée on sait très bien pourquoi ils
nous tirent dessus c'est pas s'ils
savent que c'est leur fin ils se
préparent le seul langage qu'ils
connaissaient la violence ne va pas être
violent mais on va rester
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tram va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
l'iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avait t'il un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir et
colombier revient dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de correction nous
allons retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre pour des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoirité
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu'il avait fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 1er octobre 2020 l'étau se
resserre paris et les départements de la
petite couronne pourrait basculer en
zone d' alerte maximale dès lundi la
déclaration d'olivier ferrand tout à
l'heure lors de son point hebdomadaire
sur l'évolution de l'épidémie
du côté de bordeaux nice ou marseille
c'est un début d'embellie sanitaires
même si les niveaux de circulation du
virus y restent trop élevés la france
reste le pays qui testent le plus au
monde affirme le ministre de la santé
avec plus d'un million de tests réalisés
par semaine un référendum sans gestes
barrières la nouvelle calédonie qui a
échappé à l'épidémie de coronavirus vote
sur son indépendance ce dimanche lors
d'une première consultation en 2018
le non l'emportait à 56 4 % contre 43 6%
pour le oui l les accords de matignon et
de nouméa prévoit pas moins de trois
référendum si le nom l'emportent à
chaque scrutin
si c'est le oui qui l'emportent la voie
de l'indépendance devra être suisse
[Musique]
à londres dernier jour des auditions du
procès de julian assange en vue de son
extradition vers les etats-unis où il
risque une peine de 100 75 ans de prison
l'avenir du lanceur d'alerté est entre
les mains de la justice britannique
depuis la reprise du procès le 7
septembre la juge rendra sa décision le
4 janvier
[Musique]
et pour commencer retour sur le point
hebdomadaire d'olivier veillant sur
l'évolution du colis des îles c'est
terminé tout à l'heure les précisions
sur place de notre reporter estelle fage
pas de nouveaux tours de vis un mais une
mise en garde c'est le message adressé
par olivier ferrand lors de ce point
presse hebdomadaire une mise en garde
car le pays se trouve dans une phase
d'aggravation dans la circulation à du
virus
ce sont les mots du ministre de la santé
cinq métropoles inquiète
particulièrement lille lyon grenoble
saint-etienne et toulouse là bas le taux
de saturation des services de
réanimation avoisine les 30% ces villes
pourraient donc être placées en zones
d'alerté maximale la semaine prochaine
si les mesures actuellement à mise en
place ne produisent pas les effets
escomptés même son de cloche pour paris
et sa petite couronne qui pourrait se
voir placé en zone d'alerté maximale est
ce être dès lundi je vous propose à ce
propos à d'écouté olivier ferrand la
situation de la métropole parisienne
maintenant où là aussi vous voyez qu'il
ya une dégradation qui s'est accélérée
sur paris et la petite couronne depuis
hier en effet dans les dernières 24
heures
paris a franchi les trois seuils qui
peuvent correspondre à la zone dite d'
alerte maximale
ce franchissement des seuils nous
l'observons que depuis quelques heures
nous avons besoin évidemment de le
confirmer dans les tout prochains jours
mais si ça devait se confirmer nous
n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
placer paris et la petite couronne en
zone d' alerte maximale et ce dès lundi
enfin concernant les villes de marseille
bordeaux ou encore nice de timides
améliorations ont été observées mais ces
résultats doivent être confirmés dans
les prochains jours un signe
d'encouragement pour olivier ferrand à
poursuivre et à tenir à les efforts
sachez enfin que le gouvernement va
examiner dans les projets dans les
prochains jours des propositions des
représentants est des restaurateurs à
ces derniers sont mécontents à d'avoir
dû fermer à leurs établissements
notamment à marseille et bien si ces
règles sont validées par le haut conseil
scientifique
elles pourront à permettre à ces
derniers de garder à leur établissement
ouvert
même dans les zones d'alerté maximale et
les derniers chiffres de santé publique
france l agence annonce près de 14000
nouvelles contaminations convient de 19
ans 24 heures soixante trois personnes
sont décédées à l'hôpital et 844
patients sont actuellement en
réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests se situe
lui à 7,6 pour cent et pour parler de la
situation sanitaire et de la
communication du gouvernement
nous sommes avec et nicolas vidal
directeur de la publication de putsch
médias nicolas vidal bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur elle
c'est france
alors première réaction peut être au
point d'olivier ferrand finalement on a
entendu en des termes plutôt positif
frémissement positif par exemple même si
le virus circule activement
quel est votre regard sur cette
communication hebdomadaire du
gouvernement elle est nécessaire à leur
premier recteur observations moi j'ai
trouvé qu'on a voulu dire ça va mieux
mais ça va moins bien
olivier ferrand vous l'avez vu le roi
j'ai noté la présence comme tout le
monde comme vous et tout le monde de la
raison du docteur chrono fontanier je
les ai vus comme un maître de stage en
eau fontani pasco libérant a une
nouvelle fois à mon avis un gros doute
ou la capacité sur la légitimité à dire
là à dire la situation est donc on nous
avait finalement une espèce de cours
d'infectiologie avec des graphiques des
pauvres compte on se serait cru dans un
séminaire et je trouve que sa démarche
sa demande finalement les capacités aviv
et veyran a abandonné et donner une
politique claire et surtout que les
français croient ce qu'ils racontent aux
différents voilà pour la première
observation que j'ai fait on va dire
purement pratique pas de mesures
restrictives annoncé ce soir
est ce que ça veut dire que les maires
ont eu gain de cause c'était certains
ont rencontré un leur premier ministre
ce matin
ou alors est-ce que c'est l'état qui se
donne un peu de sursis car
l'acceptabilité des français c'est
violent vous avez raison il vient
effectivement on a vu des puits de
martine aubry le moudenc aussi à
toulouse par hollywood 1
un toulouse effectivement qui sont
réjouis qu'on leur laisser un espèce de
sursis et puis je voudrais camille noter
quelque chose finalement les
restaurateurs avec leurs francs de
l'heure jacques leriche d oser dire en
ligue 1 ne croise pas ce qu'il ya eu un
manifestement rétropédalage de la part
du gouvernement qui quand même pris une
fronde et en notant aussi que
considérant ou par de concertation la
concertation à marseille tester pas
l'idée que la présentation c'est à dire
qu'on va imposer à marseille que des
mesures extrêmement coercitives et je
suis pas l'idée que chaque matin leur
tentation par bon surtout quand jean
castex se veut le premier ministre des
territoires lob de prades
voilà on ne connaît pas on n'est pas des
plus dans la concertation de ce côté là
justement pour les restaurateurs est ce
que vous avez senti un deux poids deux
mesures entre marseille contre paris
lyon grenoble et comment vous pourriez
l'expliqué finalement alors je me
définir comme un virus
auroux et bien vous savez c'est george
orwell 1984
finalement on sent qu'on lui de
convaincre compétitivité des bars les
restaurants mais par contre en ce qui
concerne br les métro les bus et tout ce
qui fait les centres commerciaux aussi
le biais but apparemment réussi attaque
par donc on peut comprendre dans quel
sport à faire même en tant que français
se poser légitimement la question de
savoir quelle est la cohérence de ces
dispositifs de ses mesures sanitaires
on a du mal à comprendre pour ceux qui
habitent à paris en convoi les lignes de
métro bondée le matin les erreurs banc
des lions vient de dire aux
restaurateurs que ça sera même deux
heures pour l'instant est peut-être une
fermeture totale dès le 10 6 finalement
une paris passe en alerte maximale comme
d'autres métropoles
donc on ne comprend absolument rien il
nouvelle fois ça et quand la légitimité
de la politique du gouvernement sur ces
questions là en tout nous en tout cas
effectivement paris qui pourrait passer
en zone d' alerte maximale dès lundi
pourquoi lundi pourquoi pas ce soir là
encore un flottement vous trouvez du
gouvernement bien entendu personne moi
ce qui me ce qui m'effraie dans cette
dans ses déclarations et ça c'est vrai
depuis le début c'est à dire qu'on fait
une politique du flux tendu
on est à 30 % d'occupation des docks
auvitu la réanimation et la réalité
c'est la question que je pose de france
ce soir combien
y avait-il de lits de réanimation en
mars combien y at-il de l'hydre
animations aujourd'hui au 1er octobre
2020 c'est à dire que le gouvernement ne
veut pas dépasser le seuil des 30% mais
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec la
casse dans l'hôpital public on n'a pas
mis des moyens sur l'hôpital
rappelez-vous olivier le grand discours
d' emmanuel macron à mulhouse qui nous a
dit la main sur le coeur je vais faire
un grand plan sur l'hôpital
la réalité c'est qu'il ya pas de plan
d'eau potable on m'aurait parcours dans
des murs mais l'arrêté aussi c'est qu'il
ya aujourd'hui des urgences qui sont en
grève qui sont remis aux élèves
quiconque au gouvernement avec cette
politique du flux tendu donc on préfère
finalement mettre en veille avec une
série les restaurateurs les bars tout
série d'activités finalement pour
masquer aussi que l'impéritie du
gouvernement reprendre en mai l'hôpital
public lui donner des moyens ouvrir des
lits terrell délit pérenne et on parlera
aussi de bousquet respirateur plus rares
et puisqu'il fait aussi la réanimation
qu'on reste pas dans les meilleures
conditions pour les patients que nous
sommes est citoyen français qu'une fois
mais olivier vidal comment vous le
comprenez parce qu'au fond d'un côté on
a des centaines de milliards débloqués
assez rapidement pour pour l'économie de
l'autre effectivement dans la 106 long
que sa traîne pour l'hôpital public et
même bien avant le coup vide nous ici rt
france on a couvert de nombreuses
manifestations de deux soignants de
médecins qui alertait justement sur
l'état de l'hôpital public comment est
ce que vous comprenez finalement que ça
traîne un petit peu sur ce dossier là
bas parce que butelle public je vais
revenir je vais refaire un petit musique
de l'union européenne aujourd'hui on
avait une volonté de ne pas augmenter
les visites publiques d'austérité de
paupérisation de privatisation de tous
les services publics ça passera aussi
par l'hôpital est basée par les
autoroutes c'est de passer par les
barrages et toute une série de choses
adp eut autres et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
envie de mettre le paquet pour prendre
au mot créé une bulle d un trivial sur
l'hôpital public parce que c'est
investir massivement dans les services
publics et l'union européenne s'y oppose
farouchement etc s'oppose farouchement
et notre côté aussi
je précise une dernière chose que
j'oubliais c'est qu'on n'a pas fermé les
frontières aussi pendant pendant la
crise du commis de la france était le
seul pays à atteindre les frontières
vont finalement la cadre l'hôpital
public et la ville l'idéologie
néolibérale fécond espèce de monstre
sommes absolument d'austérité et on ne
veut pas mettre de l'argent dans le
service public on privatise à fond voilà
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve en
situation est manifestement ces gens là
n'ont pas compris ou ne veulent pas
investir massivement dit on nous sort
toujours de la communication
gouvernementale en permanence et ça ne
passe plus auprès des français des
français et à juste titre alors ce matin
emmanuel macron s'est lui aussi exprimé
sur la situation sanitaire et économique
en france devant un parterre de chefs
d'entreprise
il a dit il a appelé les chefs
d'entreprise à ne pas douter à investir
même si on sait pas trop où on va
comment est ce que vous comprenez ces
déclarations manuel la grande invitée
immédiat des postures de chef de l'état
concrètement aujourd'hui qu'on voit on
peut citer bridgestone on peut citer
auchan on peut citer dans swiss en train
de licencier massivement face à une
mondialisation effrénée et aujourd'hui
quand vous avez un mono le maire
-ministre de l'économie je le précise
qui supplie les chefs d'entreprise ou
les grands groupes à ne pas appliquer la
directive travers des tâches et l'état
la réalité l'a perdu ses pouvoirs
régaliens d'imposer un moment donné sa
souveraineté
donc aujourd'hui on est ouvert aux
quatre vents et on est en concurrence
avec le monde entier avec l'europe ans
pour commencer par l'europe au regard
des plumes question reprend là dessus
les haies stone va délocaliser en
pologne en hongrie et par fermer son
usine son usine avec une donc
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que bruno le
maire ne fait que supplier conseiller
susurré mais ne peut rien imposer donc
avec sexy du bolide et avec la
mondialisation ça va être une
convergence d'une double crise sociale
populaire qui va être absolument
terrible et on commence à voir les
effets on commence à voir les effets dès
maintenant et ça va être très
sincèrement
on voit très inquiet de la situation
économique dans les douze à
effectivement le soccer populaire alerte
et hier peut-être pour conclure toujours
sur la question économique et les
secteurs protégés indemnisé à 100%
jusqu'à fin décembre suffisant selon
vous alors que sincèrement je ne
pourrais pas en tant que journaliste je
dispute avec pas mal de restaurateurs
des tricks dix jours même depuis très
longtemps mais depuis dix jours
particulièrement ses 500 ces gens là ne
voit pas ces prêts arrivés ne boit pas
et donc on peut c'est une espèce de
décision on veut dire un qui vient d'en
haut verticale et on ne voit absolument
pas pour ces gens je ne vois absolument
pas le bien qu'ils ont aujourd'hui donc
c'est bien joli de prendre des
précautions
là dessus ou des décisions mais à un
moment donné il faut aussi que le le
restaurateur le casting tout la france
puisse immédiatement touché des aides
parce que sinon ces gens sont en train
de monde et qui sont en train de mourir
donc vous savez les déclarations on peut
aussi qu'elle se réalise dans les actes
sur les territoires il y avait encore
une espèce de déconnexion d'un décalage
technocratique qui est en train de
mettre le pays à genoux et tout france
périphérique il avait tourné je le
rappelle merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal d'avoir partagé votre
réflexion je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de publication de putsch
médias il y a deux ans les électeurs
calédonien avait majoritairement voté en
faveur du maintien de la nouvelle
calédonie au sein de la république
française et ce dimanche
un deuxième référendum est organisé il
pourrait être suivi d'un troisième
le point tout de suite avec leïla sarraf
le non l'avait emporté avec 56,7 % des
voix le 4 novembre 2018 les électeurs
calédonien avait voté en faveur du
maintien de la nouvelle calédonie au
sein de la république française ce
dimanche
un deuxième référendum est organisé avec
la même question
alors pourquoi ce deuxième round
conformément à l'accord de nouméa signé
le 5 mai 1998 sont prévues jusqu'à 3
vote en cas de victoire du non au
référendum d'autodétermination
si le nom l'emportent de nouveau ce
dimanche un troisième référendum pourra
donc être organisées à la condition
qu'au moins un tiers des membres du
congrès de nouvelle calédonie le
demandent un nouveau scrutin sera alors
organisée dans les deux ans en cas de
oui
l'archipel de vienne et indépendant elle
devra adopter une constitution veut
l'indépendance s'arrête là c'est plutôt
une question de dignité et par rapport à
nous les jeunes c'est plutôt par rapport
à ça pour que nous puissions avoir un
pays et pour que nous puissions la
grandeur de l'homme emad en 2018 la
participation avait atteint un record
80% des électeurs avait voté à la
surprise générale l'écart entre le oui
et le non avait été bien plus serré que
prévu
pas de raz-de-marée donc en faveur du
maintien dans la république française
vous l'aurez compris si la nouvelle
calédonie est l'un des très rares
territoires au monde à avoir échappé à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19
ces habitants qui mène une vie sans
masque ni gestes barrières ont malgré
tout un choix importants à faire et pour
en parler nous sommes avec alban bensa
anthropologue spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie bonsoir alban bensa merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
beaucoup s'accordent à dire que
contrairement au précédent référendum
l'atmosphère est plus tendue cette année
en nouvelle calédonie est ce que c'est
votre avis est ce que le climat a changé
oui je pense que le climat a un petit
peu changé parce que le premier
référendum ce qui appelait à voter in on
pensait qu'ils allaient l'emporter
largement
et ils ont eu la surprise de voir que
comme mischa gang 6% des voix et les
biens des partys 44% mais l'écart et
était plus réduit que que prévu donc
ce qu'ils font qui appelle à voter non
on est un peu peur que l'un des plus
actifs progresse encore peut-être fait
cette fois ci ça fait une des raisons
des tensions fin des tensions de vue de
la montée de l'inquiétude de 10 ans
d'arrêt et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que la france semble perplexe
la france semble que l'état français
s'en tient à ce rôle d arbitre qui
exaspère les français voudraient où les
calédoniens qui ne devrait que la
calédonie reste purement française donc
vivant sentent bien qu'il va falloir en
quelque sorte se mettent autour d'une
table et réfléchir ensemble pour trouver
une citoyenneté calédonienne et ce
manque de soutien de de la république
française en nouvelle calédonie est ce
qui pourrait faire basculer des
électeurs qui souhaitait toujours
appartenir à la république française et
est-ce qu'il y aura qui pourrait
basculer finalement c'est possible ou
disons qu'ils pourraient plus tôt soit à
venir pourraient s'abstenir
faute d'un dialogue véritablement
engagée est ce que la crise est ce que
la crise sanitaire est ce que vous
m'entendez allemand même ça voilà est-ce
que la crise sanitaire ont leur rond le
disert à la nouvelle calédonie
finalement très peu touchés aujourd'hui
pas du tout même par le locaux vides 19
est ce que cette crise sanitaire peut
avoir un impact sur le vote pourrait
avoir un impact positif pour vous pour
tout le monde dans le sens où les
calédoniens peut dire nous nous avons
été joués le virus nous avons repoussé
les attaques du coran coronavirus par
des mesures extrêmement strictes prises
d'ailleurs avant avant l'étape rentrée
dix jours avant et en repoussant tout
atterrissage tout avion tout contact
avec l'extérieur
donc ils administrent la preuve qu aux
comptes
n'applique de façon extrêmement stricte
des règles barrières et bien on a pas de
cas alors sa fille effet sur un
l'histoire de la nouvelle calédonie
c'est une île et les épidémies ont fait
des ravages dans libre auditeurs jeune
tchèque en particulier auprès des kanak
n'est pas seulement
et donc les gens ont un souvenir amer de
chez du cbi délit ils veulent absolument
pas renouer avec une triste période
alors quels sont les arguments
aujourd'hui de chaque camp pourquoi les
indépendantistes veulent sortir de la
france et en finir avec la colonisation
pourquoi les non-indépendantistes
veulent y rester c'est pour le la
stabilité économique
alors les donne neuf indépendant tiff
que le vérifier par qui sont
principalement installées à nouméa et
aussi un peu à bourail et parce qu'il
n'y fit fille largement de l'économie
sous perfusion qui a été installé en
nouvelle calédonie des lois de
défiscalisation et surtout de l'argent
français qui vient compenser ou amant
d'amendé ou abonder dans le beach et de
la nouvelle calédonie mais en même temps
c'est ignorer que la nouvelle calédonie
à ses propres ressources et notamment
dans le nord où les économistes gère une
usine de retraitement du nickel et un
assist de nickel alors les
indépendantistes eux s'appuyer sur ce
succès s'appuie sur l'amélioration des
conditions de vie dans les endroits où
de petites habitudes sauf quelques
poches de pauvreté ya justement en
province sud
a nouméa ou des anti indépendantistes
sont majoritaires plus profondément
si vous voulez c'est un problème de
souveraineté est un problème c'est à
dire de pouvoir
lise indépendantistes et mouvances qui
se trouvent autour de calédoniens
souhaite exercer pleinement le pouvoir
sur la terre calédonienne qu'ils
considèrent comme leur appartement par
appartement et ne veulent plus dépendre
d'eux
de la france attendait manière des
règlements des fiches genève indique pas
la question foncière à questions que
j'avais dit que les questions sociales
etc considère qu'ils sont assez grands
maintenant pour voler de leurs propres
ailes et il inspire à une souveraineté
une souveraine clic sera une
souveraineté dans une société plurielle
c'est à dire on les différentes
communautés
je trouverais leurs plages pour
travailler ensemble exercer ensemble un
pouvoir indépendant sur les ressources
de la nouvelle-calédonie suffirait à
faire vivre toute toute la population
calédonienne
pour l'instant les ressources sont à
fait qu'amd du fait du nickel mais comme
vous le savez le cours du nickel est
lui-même tributaire de la situation
internationale avec des avec des hauts
et des bas et je pense qu'il faut pas se
voiler la face que s'il y avait une
indépendance de demain matin et si la
france ne continuaient pas acheter ce
processus de décolonisation aurait
certainement des difficultés tant que la
calédonie pourra pas développer
elle-même ses propres ressources à ce
que pour l'instant à 80% des produits
sont importés et ce qui importe ce sont
justement ceux qui quels le plus à
rester tant dans la france que comme il
est évident à bangui et il gagne
beaucoup à ce régime d'importation par
contre il y avait un régime plus fort de
développement de la pêche de
l'agriculture de l'informatique des
services chez que terrain la calédonie
pourrait comme tous les autres pays du
pacifique faut quand même noter être
indépendante dans des conditions
certainement moins vie réelle que celle
nos ordis vous avez des écarts de
fortune chez domino mais d'une façon
tout à fait honorable et notamment en
renforçant les liens ce qui avait déjà
été fait à l'époque de michel rocard
avec l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande
et pour conclure il ya une véritable
unité culturelle aujourd'hui entre les
habitants entre les calédoniens ya
peut-être pas l'une unis
et culturels mais il ya l'histoire
événement est une histoire vécue
ensemble mémoire commune petit à petit
j'ai forgé notamment dans ses trente
années
la révision des manuels scolaires
la multiplication des spectacles
interculturel et malgré tout la
recherche de liens de liens anciens
entre les différentes communautés
ce qui fait que tout le monde est un peu
cousin de tout le monde et aujourd'hui
il ya des décors un changement familiaux
qui traverse les communautés techniques
donc il ya un sentiment de singularité
calédonienne le très très fort qui fait
que la plupart des calédoniens sur la
plus longtemps nouvelle calédonie
aujourd'hui se sentent pas à l'aise
lorsqu'ils sortent de la nouvelle
calédonie que ce soit les kanaks où les
noms kanak parce que la calédonie existe
commun comme un pays si vous voulez elle
existe en tant que tel avec des
particularités alimentaire relationnel
des codes sociaux et une histoire qui a
fait beaucoup de progrès ces dernières
années c'est-à-dire la reconnaissance
d'une histoire commune des gens qui
tenaient du panier gentil gel de la
colonisation libre les gens avec les
accidents et donc je pense qu'elle est
chèrement en tous les cas possibles
d'une citoyenneté calédonienne et pour
défendre cette citoyenneté calédonienne
ouvrir un dialogue ce qui fait qu'il ya
de plus en plus de gens qui feraient
prêt à dialoguer mais encore faut-il que
il ya une volonté le politique à la fois
de la part de l'état français pour
favoriser le dialogue et surtout de la
part de ceux qui y voient la maintient
dans la france sans confession très bien
eh bien écoutez
merci infiniment alban bensa pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
anthropologue et spécialiste de la
nouvelle calédonie et ont fait un point
sur le procès en france maintenant et
des attentats de charlie hebdo et de
l'ip
cacher de janvier 2015 il se poursuit à
la cour d'assises spéciale de paris
quatorze suspects sont accusés d'avoir
fourni à des degrés divers un soutien
logistique aux trois assaillants
les frères chérif et saïd kwasi et à
mehdi coulibaly les précisions sur place
de notre reporter katia technique est
l'homme clé de toute cette affaire c'est
claude hermant une figure du mouvement
identitaire qui a vendu des armes
démilitarisées donc c'est légal selon
lui en le soupçonne de les avoir re
militarisée est là pour cela ils se
défaussent sur à d'autres hommes sami
ladjali mais il est introuvable lui
aussi devait témoigner mais donc il ne
le fera pas et ce qui est assez étonnant
dans toute cette histoire c'est que
claude hermant et est un indic donc sa
ligne de défense est de dire que les
gendarmes étaient parfaitement au
courant de son trafic et quillan filtrer
pour eux seulement les gendarmes ont
réfuté ces affirmations en disant qu'il
n'était pas du tout au courant du trafic
d'armes de claude hermant pourtant il
avait eu vent d'un trafic d'armes
démilitarisé cela aurait pu les mettre
sur la piste mais ils ont jugé bon de ne
pas ouvrir d'enquêté et cela surprend
les avocats de la défense
à commencer par isabelle coutant-peyre
l'avocate du principal prévenu on les
coûts' établi que ces armes là c'est des
armes lourdes des armes de guerre et que
le commissaire petits sons qui avait été
aux renseignements généraux est
immédiatement informé la police
judiciaire de lui ce qu'on constate
c'est que
et n'empêche que ce trafic a continué et
que les armes se sont retrouvés dans les
mannequins du valide que ce sont toutes
ces armes là sion qui sont à l'origine
de ces drames de janvier 2004 donc il ya
un dysfonctionnement mais pas seulement
des fautes extrêmement graves commises
aussi bien par les services de
gendarmerie les douanes et la police
judiciaire et c'est là où sont les
responsabilités sans parler de la dg ce
qu'on peut retenir de cette journée
c'est qu'il y a peut être eu des
manquements également peut-être des
mensonges en tout cas il subsiste de
grandes zones d'ombré sur le trajet des
armes de claude hermant à amedi
coulibaly et dans quelques instants
direction londres au dernier jour des
auditions du procès de julian assange le
fondateur de wikileaks tente de faire
échec à une demande américaine
d'extradition visant la publication de
documents secrets en 2010 à la justice
britannique rendra sa décision le 4
janvier rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune et colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche dont intérêts de
leurs populations
oui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur arte france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
un dernier jour des auditions du procès
de julian assange l'avenir du lanceur
dallaire est entre les mains de la
justice depuis la reprise du procès le 7
septembre on le rappelle il risque une
peine de 100 75 ans de prison la
décision sera rendue le 4 janvier
alors qu'un témoin anonyme affirme que
les états unis voulaient le kidnapper
voir l'empoisonner meriem les ribi
journaliste travaillant pour le site web
de rt france rt france 2 points tv
revient pour nous sur le procès de
julian assange
plusieurs thématiques ont été abordées
durant les deux dernières semaines de
procès tout d'abord la santé de julian
assange la santé mentale de julian
assange
ensuite les conditions de détention du
journaliste s'il venait à être extradé
aux états unis et enfin la relation de
ce procès avec celui qui se déroule en
espagne contre la société de
surveillance us et globales
tout d'abord concernant la santé de
julian assange deux psychiatres qui
l'ont longuement ausculté et analyser
son cas font état que le journaliste
souffre d'une forme d'autisme et plus
précisément du syndrome d'asperger
guerre sa détention prolongée et la
perspective de l'extradition leur font
craindre je cite un risque élevé de
suicide selon l'un des deux psychiatres
julian assange aurait déjà a commencé à
préparer à se préparer à mettre fin à
ses jours en écrivant des lettres
d'adieu à ses proches et en rédigeant un
testament
ensuite dans les jours qui ont suivi la
cour a pu entendre
des témoins qui ont attesté du fait que
julian assange s'il est extradé aux
états unis sera sera incarcéré sous un
régime extrêmement sévères qui ne lui
permettra pas d'avoir accès à d'autres
détenus ni même à un suivi psychiatrique
réguliers tels que son état de santé le
nécessite
ensuite il ne pourra pas non plus avoir
un accès satisfaisant à ces avocats ni
même avoir des visites de ses proches il
ne pourra par exemple pas toucher ses
enfants s'ils viennent lui rendre visite
en prison aux états unis
ensuite le la cour a entendu des témoins
concernant le procès qui se déroule
actuellement contre le la société us et
globales en espagne alors la société us
et globales est une société espagnole de
surveillance qui étaient chargés de
surveiller l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres or cette société aurait selon
l'accusation dépasser ses prérogatives
et espionner intensivement assange au
profit des autorités américaines et
c'est ce dont l'accusent donc julian
assange est la relation avec le procès
qui se tient actuellement à londres et
concerne le fait que si les états unis
l'accusation américaine a pu écouter va
traverser de cet espionnage du ca global
les échanges qui a eu du lan assange
avec ses avocats
alors elle savait avant même la tenue de
ce procès le contenu de la stratégie de
défense de julian assange et pour cela
pour la défense cela est très
problématique
alors quelles ont été les derniers
événements avant la reprise du procès de
julian assange la réponse tout de suite
en images
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
julien assange un procès historique pour
un homme qui risque d'être extradé vers
les états unis et d'écoper 175 ans de
prison pour tenter de décrypter les
enjeux d'un tel procès nous sommes avec
françois corbère de l'association robins
à des lois et viktor dedaj fondateur du
site le grand soir messieurs messieurs
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur été france alors avant de vous
entendre
je vous propose de démarrer avec ce
tweet d'eric dupond-moretti c'était en
fait en février dernier il était alors
avocats de julian assange
nous allons demander à rencontrer le
président de la république dans les
jours qui viennent pour ne pas dire dans
les heures qui viennent
alors françois cau robert votre
association robin des lois souhaite donc
le fondateur de wikileaks obtiennent
l'asile politique en france
eric dupond moretti est aujourd'hui et
garde des sceaux alors on a vu ce tweet
est ce que cela peut aider votre cause
écoutez je dirais que dupont moretti est
devenu un adversaire
nous nous battons nous depuis un an avec
un projet extrêmement technique met au
point par emmanuel ludot qui est un de
nos avocats habituel qui tint un très
bon spécialiste des questions pénales et
procédurales pour obtenir l'asile c'est
à dire que il ya deux façons d'obtenir
l'asile en france je crois que c'est
important pour éclaircir le débat au
départ vous avez l'asile qui est
accordée par le président de la
république et donc le nom on appelle ça
la zil constitutionnel c'est ce qu'a
demandé dupond moretti
la requête est encore avocat brièvement
des changes le 20 février dans une
conférence de presse retentissante et à
l'asie qu'on obtient par l'ofpra qui est
l'organisme national qui et à n'importe
quel demandeur d'asile s'adresse qu il
soit au mali au maroc il est réfugié en
france
il demande la zea l'ofpra qui se trouve
juridiquement âcre et iphone tribunal de
créteil fontenay mais pour pouvoir
demander l'asile à l'ofpra
il faut être sur le territoire français
et c'est l'enjeu que
que nous portons depuis quelques mois
jusqu'à présent on l'avait fait très
discrètement en le proposant aux avocats
d'assange pour qu' il ya une dérogation
qui soit obtenu en justice ça peut faire
très vite pour que julian assange soit
autorisé à déposer une demande d'asile à
l'ofpra et non pas en suppliant de
présenter république qui veut qui veut
pas enfin vous connaissez les
hésitations et puis quelques années là
dessus puisque hollande avait refusé une
demande qui avait été formulée dans le
monde
bon donc nous avons l'intention de
saisir et on va le faire dans les jours
qui viennent en référé le tribunal de
créteil pour que justin st je suis
autorisé pour que nous soyons autorisés
à demander une dérogation je vous passe
le détail c'est assez technique et nous
pensions depuis un an qu'il faut
demander l'asile que c'est la seule
solution
avec ce procès qui est enlisé avec ce
délibéré qui comme par hasard est fixée
après la fin du brésil
c'est à dire le 4 janvier pourquoi parce
que l'âge il permet actuellement l'état
du traité de dublin si imaginons demain
que le présente la république accorde
l'asile à julian assange
l'angleterre est obligé de le remettre à
la france y aurait un bras de fer
diplomatique je passe les détails mais
du fait des accords de dublin
l'angleterre serait obligé de le laisser
venir en froid mais il reste trois mois
donc il reste extrêmement peu de temps
pour obtenir l'asile
donc quand dupond moretti a annoncé
j'étais à la conférence de presse avec
beaucoup d'émotion qu'il allait demander
l'asile immédiatement sous peu dans
l'urgence on est tous d'accord c'était
ce qu'il fallait faire en dépit des
hésitations des avocats anglais qui
disait on attend de voir le procès
commence à tourner bon très bien mais
nous on disait il faut à peu ils
arrivent en disant je vais demander
l'asile
bravo on applaudit j'ai aucune
antipathie jeune j'admirais le grand
avocat qu'il était au moins le cas
aujourd'hui en tout cas aujourd'hui ça
ne veut ça ne peut pas bouger de
maintenant qu'il est garde des sceaux
d'à côté on l'a mis dans un article du
monde le 21 août on a publié une lettre
ouverte en avait eu assez d'attendre
puisqu'il a complètement oublié ses
déclarations fracassantes et où te et il
nous a répondu qu'il nous recevrait
quand il aurait le temps aux 50 qui
penserait donc on a rendu publique on
lui a rappelé ses souvenirs mais c'était
au moins d'août
il a écouté il ya quatre mois devant 100
journalistes nous l'avait dit que vous
alliez
en de l'asile d'urgence parce
qu'effectivement il était arrivé de
londres 10 ans qui n'était pas bien
qu'il fallait d'urgence de man et puis
oublié et je pense que c'est scandaleux
que celui qui a été un grand avocat et
trahi cette course parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'explication en août a pas fait dire
attendez il réfléchit aucun jeune alliés
qui me la poser la question frontalement
depuis le mois d'août mais il faudrait
la lui poser enfin on va essayer dans
les quinze jours qui viennent de la plus
posée qu'est ce que vous attendez on
n'est pas compétent lui pour accorder
l'asile mais il a évidemment le flux
direct avec le peu d'intérêt que lui
pour faire pour faire effectivement
bouger les choses on va entendre victor
déjà un fondateur du site le grand soir
peut-être sur le fond alors les avocats
de julian assange
aujourd'hui rappelle le caractère
journalistique des travaux de julian
assange
pourquoi il n'a pas dépassé
effectivement son rôle de journaliste
selon vous pourquoi il n'a pas dépassé
selon le journal est journaliste et côté
y compris dans les chefs d'inculpation
présentée par les états unis au mois de
février dernier les délais faits qui lui
reprocher qui était décrit dans les
chefs d'inculpation décrivez c'est pas
moi qui parle ce sont les plus grands
journalistes d'investigation de notre
époque qui le disaient c'est bizarre
mais ça décrit exactement une de nos
journées de travail il n'y a rien de
spécial danser dans ces chefs
d'inculpation
mais ce qu'il faut constater c'est que
entre temps les américains ont changé
deux fois de fusil d épaule
lorsqu'il en juin août
ils ont présenté de nouvelles
accusations contre julian un sens
d'ailleurs qu'ils avaient présenté
d'abord à la presse pas sans même les
avoir transmis à la justice britannique
et lors des procès on a assisté à un
phénomène où les avocats américains vous
pour le gouvernement américain ou encore
une changer une deuxième fois
dangles d'attac en changeant encore les
chefs d'inculpation grand dam des
témoins qui étaient préparés à a plaidé
sur les anciens accusations et des
témoins qui sont vus remettre des
dossiers de plus de 300 pages le matin
même de leurs témoignages en direct donc
la farce à qui a démarré il ya longtemps
ça continue et genre il est clair
maintenant après les témoins qui sont
passés les uns après les autres des
témoins de haute tenue des témoins que
là
encore ont tenté désespérément de
ridiculiser et de remettre en cause
leurs compétences qui n'ont pas plancher
qui n'ont pas qui ne sont pas laissés
faire part face à des parages de
questions roulant pour des contre
interrogatoires qui ont duré parfois
quatre heures alors que la défense
n'avait droit qu'à une demi-heure pour
interroger les témoins on sent bien
qu'il y avait une sorte de parti pris
ici de que du thé la part de la juge
ils n'ont pas flanché ils ont été bien
niveau exceptionnel et ils ont
clairement démontré de a jusqu'à z que
julian assange était bien un journaliste
alors messieurs garde d'ailleurs
jésuites pour terminer c'est que les
américains sont arrivés maintenant à la
une situation qui est complètement
surréaliste selon les mots de alexander
choristes qui a sorti un article tendre
et consciencieux news il ya deux trois
jours c'est complètement surréaliste
dans la mesure où des derniers jours on
a vu les procureurs si vous voulez
américain reprochés à julian assange des
crimes dont il était incapable de citer
un seul exemple concret c'est à dire que
le grand de reproche maintenant qui lui
est faite c'est d'avoir révélé didon et
d'avoir mis des billes en danger tout en
étant incapable de citer un seul nom
oublions danger on est ici deux mois un
procès pénal ou quelqu'un les 175 ans de
prison et les accusateurs sont même pas
capables de montrer non non seulement le
l'arme du crime mais de désigner de quel
type d'armes il s'agit alors pas ça
alors messieurs peut-être de nouvelles
révélations à venir je vous propose
d'écouter le rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks
vers la fin de la journée
le juge venait sa barrette serre a
décidé de donner l'anonymat à deux
témoins importants qui doivent toujours
témoigner ici d'espagne un ancien
employé du ca global
la compagnie qui espionnait julian et
espionner les interactions de julian
avec ses avocats dans l'ambassade
équatorienne et nous entendrons bien sûr
pour qui ils travaillaient vraiment qui
payer les factures quel intérêt il
servait et bien sûr nous savons que
c'était les institutions américaines
une institution composée de trois
lettres qui cherchait julian et qui a
décidé de le faire tomber ses anciens
employés témoigneront des plans qui ont
été discutés à l'ambassade équatorienne
empoisonné de julian assange le
kidnapper faire n'importe quoi pour le
sortir de là françois quand vers ces
révélations elle peut être ça peut être
un avantage pour julian assange et ses
avocats selon vous écoutez je pense pas
être démentie par votre co invités c'est
connu des gens qui s'intéressent à ça
puisque la presse espagnole a révélé
déjà tant de contenus qui sont
confirmées aujourd'hui mais on sait que
lafarge a été écouté par tout filmé et
enregistré dans l'ambassade donc c'est
pas vraiment un scoop bon que la défense
le présente aujourd'hui avec les deux
témoins qui sont évoqués pour ça
renforce l'argument mais je crois que
c'est passer à l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est qu'à sage n'a rien à
faire en prison alors il est l'auteur d'
alerte il est journaliste cyriaque
pointeau jurdie les journalistes
évidemment je rappelle qu'il ya dix ans
les plus grands journaux du monde ont
publié une partie des fameux câbles
diplomatiques avec des commentaires que
ce soit le monde que soient les plus
grands journaux et à fin duquel à
l'époque considéré comme journaliste
alors est ce que tu as on peut même pas
discuter je crois que notre autre qu
invité a totalement raison bien sûr de
dire qu' il n'y a pas deux y'a pas
d'espionnage touchant il a fait un
travail de journaliste
après ce qu'ils étaient un peu gros
nalistes beaucoup journaliste lanceur
dallaire bon c'est pas vraiment la
question
tout ça est très secondaire par rapport
à huy victoire des laze existent eux
mans est ce qu'il ya un silence gênant
qui éludent cette actualité en france ça
c'est un constat
quand vous ne comprenez c'est
incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible parce que c'est
la sphère de presse le plus important de
mémoire d'homme les enjeux sont
éminemment important d
habib sy notamment d'après les
développements dans les dernières
audiences où les procureurs américains
je les appelle des procureurs et les
avocats mme ceux des procureurs ont
cette fois ci est carrément admis ceux
qui le nient et il n'y a pas si
longtemps c'est qu'ils se réservent le
droit les états unis se réserve le droit
maintenant de poursuivre n'importe quel
journaliste à travers le monde
pour finir et de journalistes comment
l'expliquer je n'en sais rien c'est une
affaire qui est c'est une histoire
parallèle à l'histoire du procès de
julian assange qui reste à écrire selon
moi c'est la position l'attitude des
journalistes en général
ap dans le surtout dans les médias
mainstream à part quelques exceptions
dont vous faites partie et je pense que
cette histoire reste à écrire mais je
voudrais dire que le caractère politique
du procès de julian assange ne fait plus
aucun doute et ce depuis le début en
fait il faut rappeler que je viens d'un
sage n'a jamais été sous juridiction
américaine
le fait même qu'il vienne le chercher et
ose prétendre venir le chercher était un
acte politique l'extraterritorialité n'a
pas de valeur juridique c'est un acte
politique par définition
julian assange est donc victime d'une
tentative d'enlèvement déguisé sous
forme d'un procès politique pour rester
un petit peu élégant dans l'occident
mais c'est à peu près l'équivalent de
lui mettre une cagoule sur la tête la
balance et dans le coffre d'une bagnole
landais sur un terrain vague et tout le
reste tout le reste était forcément du
même tonneau
il ne pouvait pas en être autrement
lorsque les accusations ne porte pas sur
des faits réels mais sur des motifs
politiques
alors qu'on ne pouvait pas admettre des
motifs politiques parce que je rappelle
que le club le l'accord d'extradition
dans les états unis et l'angle entre
l'angleterre et les états unis ne permet
pas d extradition pour des motifs
politiques
il s'agit d'un procès politique on a vu
pendant des semaines
les procureurs américains tentaient
désespérément de trouver une branche
auquel s'accrocher pour essayer de faire
croire que julian assange avait commis
un acte criminel de par ses activités
purement journalistique
c'est un scandale en soi le deuxième
scandale par dessus ce scandale en soi
c'est le silence des médias
et des journalistes en général il n'y a
pratiquement personne pour couvrir cette
affaire je rappelle que les 40 ong ont
été expulsées nommément de la part de
cette mystérieuse juge veut pas mener sa
part et de serre dont amnesty
international qu'ils voulaient envoyer
un observateur et je profite de
l'antenne pour l'ancien appels reçus
aujourd'hui amnesty international
justement je pense que c'est assez de
tergiversations je vais dans le sens de
monsieur corbère c'était une affaire
politique et c'est clairement une
affaire politique
ce pourrait ne pas être à leurs yeux une
affaire politique au début parce que la
complexité de la sphère pouvait donner
l'impression que mais aujourd'hui c'est
clair net et précis
julian assange est un prisonnier
politique françois qui se répand à
amnesty international de déclaré julian
assange par un communiqué ou para avoir
formelle un prisonnier politique
actuellement enfermé dans une prison de
haute sécurité allons françois corbère
le mot de la fin vous rejoignez les
propos de viktor dedaj bien sûr on
pourrait parler pendant des heures sur
le corps en analyse est la nôtre et on
est même moi je pense que la réponse à
la question que vous posiez sur le
silence de la presse française
s'explique assez bien historiquement
tout simplement parce que c'est très
loin
nous militants juristes on a suivi
l'épisode de l'ambassade mais c'est très
très vieux faut pas oublier que ça
remonte quand même il ya dix ans les
câbles donc je pense qu'il ya eu un
temps très long pendant le qualité dans
l'ambassade où personnes globalement
s'intéresser à sa situation est donc la
presse française nous on le voit depuis
le mois d'août tourner
on est sorti du bois avec l'idée d'une
procédure qu'on va lancer dans les jours
qui viennent à créteil en essayant
d'appeler les journalistes un par un ah
oui c'est vrai bon effectivement c'est
pas de la mauvaise volonté je pense pas
qu'ils aient un complot de la presse
française
mais je voudrais lancer un appel ce soir
à tous les gens disent qu'ils nous
écoutent
il ya un scandale majeur il ya un homme
qui garde des sceaux qui est eric dupond
moretti
c'est pas rien dans la république cet
homme s'est engagé devant le monde
entier le 20 février
j'étais à la conférence de presse à dire
à celle du temps danger ces politiques
tout ce que vient de dire notre invité
on est tout à fait d'accord là dessus il
a dit quand il y avait sans journalistes
irrite la stalle j'en ai encore
l'émotion quand on réécoute la
conférence de presse
je vais dans l'heure qui vient dans les
jours qui viennent alerte elle présente
à lui au mois d'août
quatre mois après nous posons la
question dans le par le biais d'une
lettre dans le monde qui a été reprise
par la fp ça en disant monsieur dupont
moretti recevez nous on voulait savoir m
et cet homme est aujourd'hui le garde
des sceaux il faut que demain après
demain tous les journalistes y ont
prouvé qu'ils peuvent l'approcher qui
peuvent lui poser des questions lui dise
monsieur le ministre
permet-il vous êtes engagés aux yeux du
monde entier vous engager vis-à-vis de
nos journalistes
au fait vous on sait très bien que vous
n'avez pas le pouvoir d'accorder l'asile
mais voyez le président à un public
assez facilement
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire parce
qu'on est persuadé depuis le début nous
que c'est la seule chose quel que soit
le verdict qui sera rendu le 4 janvier
n'aura un appel d'un des deux côtés ça
peut durer encore très longtemps
et pendant ce temps là il ya un homme
qui n'a rien à faire en prison qui peut
y mourir
il ya un homme qui était avocat ya
encore quelques mois un des plus grands
avocats de france je le croyais je j'ai
été heureux de voir dom et j'étais
retourné tu es content si c'est bon
c'est quelqu'un qui va dans le bon sens
cet homme après il faut que tous les
journalistes dans les jours qui viennent
et le courage merci monsieur le ministre
qu'est ce que vous avez fait cette
promesse est rien mais c'est pas c'était
devant 100 journalistes du monde entier
encore une fois dans les plus grands
journaux une conférence de presse
fracassante que vous pouvez retrouver
sur facebook dans l'est avec organisée
par reporters sans frontières
je crois que c'est la question à poser
pour que le toit un détonateur un grand
merci on va on va devoir oro rendre
l'antenne le temps qui nous est imparti
est bientôt terminée donc un grand merci
en tout cas à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
françois cau robert je rappelle que vous
êtes de l'association robin des lois
merci à vous viktor dedaj fondateur du
site le grand soir et c'est la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité reste avec nous sur rt
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement